[Musique]
elie hier nous a dit qu'elle préférait
physiquement à la table elle a dit kelly
a dit mathieu de l'en but oui et oui
elle n'a intellectuelle n'a pas
intellectuellement c'est sûr que c'était
pas lui bah oui mais ça va c'est mignon
de le dire c'est vrai qu'elle a eu son
salut tu es mignon oui absolument
merci c'est brock kelly c'est vrai voilà
là le trouve très beau non c'est vrai tu
es très bon et ben hamad la révélation
pour rêver la saison et donc sépare du
picasso et maxime mathieu pourrait quoi
icloud quoi l'anglais je pourrais je
trouve très très joli et je pourrai vous
le savez je suis estate
je préfère le bo à la sexualité je
pourrais d'accord à mikkeli et je sais
pas s'ils coûtent en parlent entre eux
deux et kelly ou quoi
et bon pour les goûts pourquoi pas non
et comment dieu - non mais pour le
courageux pas du tout ce que vous pouvez
pas nous faire une petite danse tous les
deux ici à comme ça
[Applaudissements]
allez-y attention je regarde mais
c'était eux ouais pas mal mais cheryl
donc effet danse avec les stars je peux
te dire ce n'était pas du tout dans le
rythme
[Rires]